one of the things you would want to be
sure to do is whether you like it or not
get very comfortable with public
speaking for example I mean let's say an
asset that will last you 50 or 60 years
and it's a liability if you don't like
doing it or uncomfortable doing it it's
a necessary skill one of the big things
that all startups do is they lie to
themselves mine's faster mine's cheaper
mine's better no it's not and the reason
it's not is because whoever it is you're
competing with it's not like they're
ignoring you it's not like oh my
goodness this guy just started on
Shopify and the startup competition he's
doing a million dollars this year what
are they doing I'm going to copy what
they're doing and now you've got to stay
ahead you know you've got to be very
careful as an entrepreneur to be
brutally honest with yourself and those
are some of the things that you'll hear
from me as a mentor that you know know
what you know know what you don't know
but you've got to know your business
better than anybody hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because of my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit my business
partner and the thing that kept me going
was studying the stories of famous
entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the 10 skills
that can get you rich enjoy
skill number three is having confidence
I don't know if you'd agree with me on
this but in many ways one of the key
factors
to Legendary success
isn't your natural ability it's not
whether you have the right product it's
not whether you're in the right field
it's not whether you've had a blessed
background
it's not whether you have the right IQ
I want you to really think about and
deconstruct and play with maybe later
tonight in your Journal I want you to
deconstruct this idea of confidence and
it seems like a very simple word but
just think about it in your own life
when you have confidence or we could
even call it fire when you have that
Fire Within you that confidence that
interior bravery
you almost
have this power to do whatever it takes
to get your Brave Vision done
you see
in this world it's not about you know in
many ways your strategy in your business
or your ability in your life it's about
this thing called confidence and we have
all had these times in our lives when we
are full of confidence and what other
people see is a problem we simply do see
as an opportunity other people see it as
a stumbling block or a wall and we see
it as a stepping stone or this
solution and so confidence is something
that you really want to wire in
confidence is something you really want
to develop confidence is a practice
confidence is a muscle and like any
muscle the more you focus on it and
practice it and train it the stronger
your confidence is going to grow and I
just have to say it again when you are
at a place in your life when there is an
ongoing steady stream of confidence
moving through your mindset moving
through your heart set
you do the heroic in your business and
you achieve the remarkable in your life
skill number four
what's the name Nelson Mandela is
a particularly special case study in the
leadership world because he is
universally regarded as a great leader
you can take other personalities and
depending on the nation you go to we
have different opinions about other
personalities but Nelson Mandela across
the world is universally regarded as a
great leader
he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he was asked one day
how did you learn to be a great leader
and he responded that he would go with
his father to tribal meetings
and he remembers two things when his
father would meet with other Elders one
they would always sit in a circle
and two
his father was always the last to speak
you will be told your whole life that
you need to learn to listen I would say
that you need to learn to be the last to
speak
I see it in boardrooms every day of the
week even people who consider themselves
good leaders who may actually be decent
leaders will walk into a room and say
here's the problem here's what I think
but I'm interested in your opinion let's
go around the room it's too late
the skill to hold your opinions to
yourself until everyone has spoken does
two things one it gives everybody else
the feeling that they have been heard it
gives everyone else the ability to feel
that they have contributed
and two you get the benefit of hearing
what everybody else has to think before
you render your opinion the skill is
really to keep your opinions to yourself
if you agree with somebody don't nod yes
if you disagree with somebody don't not
know
simply sit there take it all in and the
only thing you're allowed to do is ask
questions so that you can understand
what they mean and why they have the
opinion that they have you must
understand from where they are speaking
why they have the opinion they have not
just what they are saying
and at the end you will get your turn
it sounds easy it's not
practice being the last to speak that's
what Nelson Mandela did also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there skill number five is managing your
time I think um like people have two
sets of resources right that they
allocate that they've got time they've
got money yeah and so if you look at
someone's bank statement and you look at
their calendar you know what their life
is and you can also predict whether life
is going to be in x amount of years
right and so if someone wants to change
what their life is going to look like
you have to reallocate where you're
investing the resources that you have
and so from a Time perspective people
who are poor in my opinion spend a lot
of time not doing stuff and that sounds
terrible to say but like at the base
level they're distracted they're not
doing the right stuff right well I was I
would even say not doing anything just
distracting them right playing video
games Netflix Etc you know all that
stuff right so they've got there's like
the basis like they don't do anything
they're purely distracting themselves
from their current state which is hard
because it's hard to confront reality if
you're like not happy it's easier to
just distract yourself right now the
level above that is you've got people
who are operating they are working every
day but they're operating in low
leverage opportunities right so they're
they're doing things that do not give
them a lot of return on their time right
and so it's like I could work it doesn't
matter how many hours I work at
McDonald's like it's very very difficult
to come wealthy there right it's just
near impossible right
versus like you could
buy a building for 10 million dollars
and then sell to somebody else for 11
you know for 11 million dollars just get
the contract and make a million dollars
on the exchange
super high leverage right from a Time
perspective which is crazy for somebody
who doesn't have money to even
contemplate something like that but the
only way that that happened and that
required no money is skill right and so
like that's an example of like it didn't
require money to make that money that's
the skill that's required to do that and
so
first is the time right people are not
doing stuff with the time that they have
or they're doing low leverage activities
with the time they have and then they're
not trying to increase their output per
unit time which means investing in their
skill set so like one of the easiest
ways to gain leverage on your time in in
when I say leverage just for everybody
like Leverage is the difference between
inputs and outputs in a system so
um you know archimedia said if you give
me a lever long enough I can move the
world and so the same degree if you have
enough skills you can do anything right
and so skills give you leverage on your
time so you get more out of each unit of
time so if I'm a master cold caller I
will get more sales and calls booked for
the same unit of time that somebody who
sucks at it same time more output right
because they developed a skill at a
masterful level 100 yeah and so when
people are allocating their time
um they're not by percentage they're
they're kind of like consuming their
time rather than investing their time so
they're either doing nothing
four they're consuming the time rather
than putting time into getting higher
Returns on their time which is education
right and so education you can have from
like the conceptual learnings watching
stuff like this
um or and or the actual doing right and
so you know you learn taking action 100
failing messing up you know feeling like
an embarrassment and reactions yeah the
first thousand uh cold calls you make
the first thousand cold emails you do
the first thousand doors you knock on
the first thousand you know what like
you'll learn more from that than you'll
learn from every single book you read up
to that point on the concept like you'll
learn right
um and so people don't allocate nearly
enough time to that in the beginning
skill number six is stop whining so I
have this thing that I've been promoting
called no whining Wednesdays
Wednesday you cannot whine complain or
criticize
and people like well what is whining
whatever you think it is don't do it
and every time you do it you have to put
a quarter in a jar
if you whine about anything I can't I'm
tired by to me why don't you why tell me
every one of them will cost you a
quarter or complaining why don't you why
do you always how come you I always they
never up cost you a quarter then last
week I had people send me pictures of
their jaws of quarters
oh my God
but what they said to me also was this
was wonderful because I was never ever
aware of how much whining and
complaining and criticizing I do
now I've got mothers doing it with their
children so Wednesday is no whining
Wednesday
we need to practice that
we need to stop whining
about what isn't happening what we don't
have what we can't do what somebody
didn't do
we got to get it clean in 2014.
no whining
no complaining
no criticizing
skill number seven is staying present in
the moment if you're living in the past
you're going to be depressed because you
are rehashing things that happen to you
that are not going to happen again if
you're living in the future you're going
to be anxious because you are
anticipating what's coming or you're
wishing for things that aren't happening
yet being in the present is where the
gold is being in the present moment is
where you will have the greatest control
where you will feel the most at ease and
where happiness
flourishes there's a super tight
connection between happiness and the
ability to live in the present moment a
lot of people believe that happiness is
tied to the things that happen to you
not so at all in fact there is a
professor of positive psychology he's
one of the grandfathers of the movement
he teaches at the University of
Pennsylvania his name is Martin segelman
and he's studied happiness for decades
now one of the things that we've talked
about a lot is that 40 of your happiness
levels are preset by genetics
sixty percent you are in complete
control of and one of the things that
this professor has has discovered is
that it doesn't matter what's happened
to you in fact some of the people that
have had the worst things the worst
things happen to them like people that
have survived the Holocaust are actually
the happiest and most grateful people in
the world
happiness comes down to this right up
here comes down to your thoughts comes
down to your mindset it comes down to
your attitude and you are 100 control of
what you're thinking
you may not be in control of how you
feel in the moment but you can always
always always always always be in
control of what you think and that will
change how you're feeling one of the
most powerful things that you can do in
terms of think and this gets back to
strick's question is how do you be
present being present is literally
nothing more than the skill of having
your thoughts be in this moment not in
the past not in the future but right
here the way that you teach yourself how
to do that
is that the moment that you catch
yourself being distracted the moment you
catch yourself starting to worry the
moment you catch yourself drifting to
the Future drifting to the past that's a
moment of tremendous power because you
basically just woke up you basically
just notice that you're not here in this
particular moment
so use that wake-up call 54321 and
ground Yourself In This Moment the best
way to ground yourself in the moment is
to look for something in this particular
moment that you can Savor now I'm using
the word saver on purpose because it's
the word that psychologists use to
describe what happens when you find
something in this moment right now right
here right now to focus on and to
appreciate it could be literally the
questions these are these are printed
out questions from people on social
media and if I were to stop and look at
these and Savor them what I would feel
in this moment is a tremendous amount of
gratitude because people are taking the
time to write and that makes me feel
incredibly grateful and it also makes me
very happy because it means that that
the folks that are writing are taking
control of their lives and seeking out
the information that they need another
form of savoring that we can all relate
to is eating as you're eating instead of
drifting to the Future and thinking
about all the things that you need to do
or hanging out in the past and rehashing
everything that's happened during the
day be in this moment in this meal
slow down
think about the food that you're eating
think about the people that you're
sitting with and how you feel about them
and if you want to take it up a notch
actually acknowledge them hey this food
tastes amazing thank you for cooking or
I'm so glad to see you and that we get
the time to have this meal together
the small simple acts of savoring are
how you expand your happiness inside the
present moment so how do you be more
present
simple
the moment that you catch yourself in
the future in the past worrying whatever
refocus yourself right here right now
and then find something right here right
now that you can savor
and when you do that you're not only
going to be present you're going to feel
more grateful and you're going to feel a
little boost of Happiness skill number
eight being consistent
success is not um it's success in our
destination people always think that oh
my God this person's so successful
because they've had a successful movie
or a successful show but success is a
journey you have to consistently always
always be successful that's when you're
really successful because otherwise
you'll be remembered for your last
failure and I've had a few but I just
have to compensate for
um my failure by just getting up and
running the more time you take to sort
of mourn it you're wasting that much
more time in being successful so you
just have to you know perk up pick
yourself up dust yourself off and just
say all right what can I do there's
always a solution you can't expect
people always get mistaken that just
because because this year has been what
it has been it's been because I
consistently worked out for about 10
years so now I know my job enough to be
able to be appreciated for it but if I
hadn't had the last 10 years I would
never have had this year or the year
before that so success is not a destiny
Nation where you or power is not like
okay today you're powerful you have to
consistently be powerful and
consistently be successful and that is a
journey skill number nine is getting
enough sleep well first of all I
prioritize sleep
and that means making that means saying
no to things you want to do it's not
easy there is hard I think the hardest
thing yeah last night
um you know Charles Sandberg interviewed
me at the San Francisco Symphony Hall
and then I had to sign books and I would
have loved to go and have dinner with
her but I went to bed
and you know because if I hadn't got if
I had Ghana to dinner
and hadn't gotten my at least seven
hours sleep that I need and had to get
up early to do TV
I would not be enjoying being here with
you now and I'm really enjoying it and
100 present I'm not tired and I hate
being tired more than I hate anything
and skill number 10 is having empathy
thought a lot about
power of empathy
in my work it's the current that
connects me and my actual pulse to a
fictional character in a made-up story
it allows me to feel
tend feelings and sorrows and imagined
pain
and my
nervous system is sympathetically wired
and it conducts that current to you
sitting in a movie theater
and to the woman sitting next to you
and to her friend
so that we all feel
that it's happening to us at the same
time it's a very mysterious and valuable
resource of the human species
and women I think access it most
effortlessly
we cry at sad movies
we don't feel we lose face or stature or
position doing it
we see a news story that enrages us and
we
write letters through tears our hearts
pounding I've often
I used to wonder why human beings
developed these inconvenient and
embarrassing
responses this sniffling choking wet
obstruction
you know the thing that Physicians and
soldiers and
stock Traders and journalists and
fashion models and politicians and news
commentators and Venture capitalists all
must suppress in order to work most
efficiently
I thought what possible value
function could it serve in the darwinian
scheme of you know survival of the
fittest and the strongest and the most
heavily armed
no seriously I thought why and how did
we evolve
with this week
and useless
passion intact
within the Deep heart's core
and the answer as I've formulated it to
myself is that empathy is the engine
that powers all the best in US
it is what civilizes US
it is what connects us
my question is about failure so I was
just wondering what are you trying at
the moment or what do you think you'll
attempt in the future that you're not
expecting to succeed at
well
I I think I think I'm gonna stay on on
um electric cars and Rockets for a while
um
and uh
yeah it was actually never ever my
intent to to run Tesla I I kind of
but because running two companies is
quite quite a burden actually
um
[Music]
I I you know it's sometimes around
people who who think oh if you're a CEO
of the company then then they sort of
Imagine themselves if they were CEO of
the company they would Grant themselves
lots of vacation
um and do lots of fun things it's like
that doesn't work quite work but work
that way
um what you actually get is a
distillation of the the worst things
going on in the company yeah
it's like
um and uh anyway so I I that the idea of
taking on something more is uh is very
frightening
um
but uh I mean possibly at some point in
the future certainly not the near term
there are uh I think there's there's
um an opportunity to create
um an electric chat essentially
um and I do think one could create an
electric jet that that
um
it's really exciting something that
would be supersonic vertical takeoff and
Landing pure electric
um and just just a vaguely forward I
think I think that's that's a distinct I
I I'm quite confident it's doable
um provided that there's a uh a rough
doubling of the energy density
um in batteries or capacitors so you
know we basically around around the 500
watt hours per kilogram level is where
it starts to make sense
um and then there's
um I do think there's the possibility of
kind of a fifth mode of Transport uh
which I've talked about
kind of mentioned tangentially uh which
is uh like I I I I I like I call kind of
the the hyperloop with
um and um
you know
i i i i I'd like to sort of publish
something about that maybe in the next
month or two
um once Tesla's at steady state
production
um and I want to flesh it out a little
bit so that um and and pre-address some
of the rebuttals that people will come
up with
um rather than just sort of put it out
there and then happy to have the revital
occur and and have an unaddressed
rebuttal
um
but um I guess the way to think of it is
um
it's like a cross between uh a Concord
and a railgun whatever success I've had
has come more from meditation than any
other
thing any other influence and um you and
I
um no because you you're you're a
meditator your wife's a meditator we
meditated in your
um room your meditation room
um we know what it is and I'll explain
what it is
um
um it it I'll first explain what it
gives you and then I'll explain how it
gives you it gives it to you
um it gives you an Equanimity a ability
to almost rise above yourself and to see
things in this
um thoughtful way almost like uh a ninja
in a uh Ninja movie as things are coming
at them everything seem to seems slower
and you approach it and you can deal
with it in that way and it gives you
um a greater level of creativity and it
does that by uh connecting your
subconscious to your conscious it
achieves that by repeating a mantra so
here's how it works there's a sound that
doesn't have a meaning it's a sound we
could for example it could be something
like oh and mentally you repeat that
over and over again you close your eyes
you get uncomfortable position and you
repeat that and you'll find that your
mind will go to that but then it'll go
to thoughts and you just say oh it's in
thoughts and go back to home and you get
to practice it and what after a while
you'll stay in that meditation that
Mantra and then when you're in that
Mantra
um it will then disappear and then you
go into a Transcendent state in other
words you transcend and you're going
basically into your subconscious and
you're in your subconscious and your
subconscious is really what controls you
more than your conscious you know it's
just you're just not conscious of it
because when you're conscious you know
you think oh well what do I want to do
and so on but your subconscious has such
an influence of the things you've
learned in your earlier years or your
genetics or something and they're not
aware from you and when you go down into
that
um you get relief but you also
um help to make the connection between
your subconscious and your conscious and
so when they're aligned you're aligning
your emotional decisions with your
intellectual decisions so I find uh it's
an instinctual thing for me to do what
do I feel emotionally what do I feel
what do I do think about that
intellectually and then how do I
approach that in that calm way it
doesn't diminish your emotions
um uh it just is you feel them
differently and my my love is as much as
it has ever been my um or more maybe
because I feel it differently so I just
want to emphasize it doesn't take away
your emotions or anything it just puts
them in the perspective as though and
you look above yourself and you see
yourself within the life's Arc you see
the strengths and the weaknesses and how
to deal with them and you navigate
better there's three kinds of money
today that you guys got to be aware of
one is God's money and God's money is
gold and silver so this is silver and
this is gold the reason I brought it
most people don't know what it looks
like and then there's government money
which is fiat currency which is the
dollar the Yen the peso the Euro the
Yuan yeah
fake and everybody's working hard for it
it's like eating fake food or drinking
fake water that's why people are getting
sick financially because they're working
for fake money yeah okay
and um then there's fake assets which
was another part of the fake Millennial
the fake generation series
but the reason I brought this here is
most people haven't seen it this here is
real silver Plata okay
that's what it looks like and so in 1972
And this here is gold yeah
this isn't God's money this is what
God's money looks like the reason I call
it God's money is you can't fake it
you know you can fake it with a fake ETF
like a gold ETF or a silver which I
don't touch because it smells as bad as
the guys have printed that crap
you know what I mean Jesus
but this is real money so
you look at this here
when I first started buying that that
was a dollar 40. yeah today that's 16
dollars
and this here is auto gold
and the reason we brought it is most
people haven't seen or touched this is
real this is God's money why did I say
it's God's money because he was here
when the Earth was created yeah and
it'll be here when we're all dead and
gone when you're saving those fake
dollars this will still be here yeah or
those fake ETFs or those fake stocks who
here has felt some sort of rejection in
the last 30 days with your business
come on don't [ __ ] me
everybody does and you know the crazy
part is they won't tell you the truth
they'll never say uh you spent the last
four years of your life building a photo
sharing app and the truth is I don't
really care if my photos aren't
organized they'll never tell you that
just be like I think the price is a
little high
remember that five dollar ebook I
created
I had people who were like ramit love
the ebook but I don't trust PayPal but I
do trust the U.S postal service so if
you could set up a PO Box I would in
fact I'll buy two copies and like naive
ramit in 2006 I was like okay so I
actually set up a P.O box and I was like
waiting like where's my bushel full of
checks and over the course of an entire
year I received one check for 4.95
don't make my mistakes
the thing is they'll never tell you why
they'll never tell you why so I want to
show you how we handle those here's a
script I'd like to show it to you this
is from a student of ours who applied
for a program he was accepted and then
he didn't join let me read it to you hi
Karthik I noticed you were interested in
testing blah blah blah and you filled
out the application but you didn't sign
up how come the course is closed now but
I just wanted to reach out and find out
what's up
so this is written very intentionally
um first people don't like to be told
hey you said you were going to do
something and then you didn't do it they
don't like it but we still want to find
the answer to our question
um so we did a couple things in this
email we've tested this one we kept it
really short two it's super
conversational notice the phrases how
come or let me know what's up sometimes
we say out of curiosity we're not saying
you know we're not being super corporate
about it and then third we have to be
really clear we're not trying to sell in
fact the course is now closed we we
cannot collect your money we don't want
it
we get massive responses
so if you have had people who are on
your email list or in your customer base
they have not bought something from you
you're sitting on a gold mine the type
of answers we get from this are amazing
they'll say things like well I'd love to
join but you know course looks awesome
but I'm in Australia and I can't fly to
New York we're like dude it's an online
course
but that's not their fault it's our
fault for not communicating that or we
get people who say this course looks
amazing but it's really expensive and I
can't convince my husband or wife to buy
into it that's actually really valuable
so now we can add that to our FAQ so we
collect these data points at every stage
of the customer experience before the
product in the product if they refund
Etc et cetera I can't tell you enough
you have to listen to the customer hard
work will not make you rich I get driven
nuts by the amount of gurus and
influencers and whatever who want to
brag and say no one can outwork me I'm
the best in the world so many people at
work me I still make more money than
them there has to be something else one
of the things that grinds my gears about
a lot of the people that I see on
Instagram that you probably see too is
this whole like no one can outwork me
Mantra first off it's objectively false
because many people a outwork you today
be at work you have done the past see
you haven't met everyone and D it
doesn't [ __ ] matter anyways it's the
same thing when someone's like I'm the
best and you have to say you're the best
because if you don't think you're the
best it shows that you're not confident
to me I don't take that at all if
someone's like I'm the best then why
aren't you on billboards that's what the
best would look like absolutely you need
to do the work you need to put volume in
it's the only way you get better but if
you start claiming that you are the best
you cannot be outworked you are making
statements that you know are not true
why are we bragging about work because
work has very little to do with the
highest levels of the game Warren
Buffett talks about if he makes two good
decisions a year he's had a good year
and so how is it that one of the best
investors one of the best business
people in terms of measuring it by money
which is how you measure business talks
about how he does basically nothing
reads five or six hours a day eats
McDonald's and makes a couple good
decisions a year how is it that that guy
is making so much more money than the
people who are bragging about the fact
that they work so hard everyone only has
the same hours of the day anybody who
only sleeps eight hours or only sleeps
seven hours and works the remaining of
hours of the day all of them would be
tied for hardest working so what creates
output you have volume of activity and
then you have the leverage of the
activity that you're doing that's what
creates the total output in order to do
anything you must do do something there
has to be some level of energy that gets
input into the system our activity in
terms of number of activities is a very
newbie measure of success in the
beginning Warren Buffett doesn't say
I sent a thousand emails today it
doesn't talk like that he's playing a
different game Jeff Bezos didn't like
woke up at 4am today now mind you I'm
saying this is somebody who likes waking
up early we can't be as superstitious
about what matters waking up early
doesn't matter going to bed late doesn't
matter not sleeping a lot doesn't matter
the few things that matter are the
inputs that go into the system that have
the most leverage to create the most
output now if you're a newbie and you
can't get your ass off the couch then by
all means figure out how to actually get
your ass off the couch and do stuff but
then there's only so many hours and so
boom and then very quickly you hit your
capacity of work great you've maximized
that now what the leverage that we have
on that activity is going to dictate how
much we get out of it and if we do a low
leverage activity many many many times
we might get more than a high leverage
activity that gets done once a CEO who's
going to work with acquisition.com Works
virtually every hour of every day when
they come in almost everybody does
sometimes they ask they're like am I
going to be working more or like it's
impossible for you to work more but you
are going to be changing what you work
on because that's the only lever we have
there's only 24 hours so we're going to
switch it these nine out and we're going
to plop these in with higher leverage
activities and so the way that we do
that is we look at their calendars and
we look at their org chart this is how
you grow a business you look at what
they spend their time on and you see
which of these activities are low
Leverage is there anyone else in this
org chart that we can hand these
activities to and if a large percentage
of these activities are a certain type
of thing and they don't exist in their
chart then it's a role that we need to
hire the point of why I hate the concept
of no one cannot work me is that there
are many ways to win the game if you
were to think about an amazing goal as a
dragon to be slain if you are familiar
with video games in any way when you
create like a war party you have a group
of people that are going to go go on a
quest you don't just have 10 paladins or
guys who just have Shields and swords so
you've got a Healer a mage that's really
good at damage but can't take a lot of
damage you've got a paladin who can't
hit as hard but he can take a lot of
shots you find people who have
complementary skills if you're playing
football you don't have 10 running backs
the entrepreneur really should be the
coach of the team it's about organizing
the pieces and how the well they play
together that ultimately determines how
good the team is like how many times
have you seen the team with the All-Star
that has the poor Supporting Cast get
beat by the overall better team it
happens all the time a lot of
entrepreneurs as I see them are trying
to play the game like they're the star
player and they want to score all the
points but they lose to Apple because
Apple's got a team we celebrate a
specific action like work when it's
really just saying oh look there's a
paladin who can take a lot of hits cool
that's not the only thing that's
required to win I think what is more
valuable is to know what are each of the
roles that exists within the business a
b is there one of these that you map to
based on your characteristics and skill
sets and then see what is my eventual
Evolution through entrepreneurship we'll
start at the beginning which is what are
the players on the field so if you think
about it by function you've got somebody
who has to promote who's got to be a
good marketer they have to understand
how to make things known across
different platforms telling stories
building a brand providing value to an
audience that's what marketing is sales
is being able to convert that raw
attention into a sale direct response
ads sales Pages video your sales letters
Etc which is pretty much anything that's
physical products or software based
that's low ticket or it's higher ticket
People to People hand-to-hand combat who
know how to in the beginning sell and
then later train how to sell and then
later later lead people who train how to
sell these are not necessarily the same
people I've met really brilliant
marketers who suck at sales I'm really
good sales people sucking marketing then
you've got somebody who understands
product how do I make something
beautiful the guy who started Shopify
he's not CEO of Shopify he's had a
product he's a mage he knows how to cast
spells and you've got the experienced
people who are managing everything
outside of the actual product itself how
do customers engage with us how it can
provide more value how can you get an
amazing experience how do we make sure
they're hitting these Milestones this
person who knows customers experience
and customer success is not the same
person who understands product and ux
and design that's a different game which
is different the guy who knows how to
close this different guy that knows how
to promote the bigger the Enterprise
gets the more specialized the skill
becomes and the deeper The Well of
experience that people need to be they
have to be more specialized when people
are like I can't be outworked you're
bragging about the wrong thing it should
be like I can't be out recruited I can't
be outmanaged no one can build a culture
like me that's super high leverage
across the organization no one can lead
like me but no one can outwork me
it's just an irrelevant activity metric
I love working I work all the time but I
would never claim that no one works
harder than me I tend to have very good
leverage with the activities that I do I
spend tons of time writing a book in
that book prints and sells copies
forever it's a different way to play the
game and so level two of this which
player you are in the Middle Run of this
you end up segregating yourself to a
portion of the business that you're an
expert at or that you're best at CMO or
chief sales officer Chief product
officer it's not about one player being
the champion here it's about how the
team works together which then gets to
the third level of this is just about
being the coach think about what the
best coaches do they're literally trying
to head hunt the best players and
they're trying to recruit the best
people from college look at what Google
does think about their recruiting
efforts they have huge influxes
dedicated to getting the best and
smartest people out of college and they
have another ring for the best and
smartest people come out of business
school and then another one is their
very high level recruiting at the top of
the executive level the parallels
between sports and business they are
almost the same in that way now mind you
you can only have you know 10 or 11
people on the field you might have ten
thousand but if each of those players
represents a function or Department of
the business it makes more sense when we
move up the levels of Entrepreneurship
we need to make sure that we're playing
the right game and that we're using the
right metric to measure our success
final level of this is being the coach
is recruiting the top level Executives
and creating a farm system underneath to
feed into the company that you have so
you can have a sustained competitive
advantage and create a dynasty for the
team so you can create the best winning
team every year and have the soft skills
of creating culture of high performance
so that you get the most out of every
individual player and the difference
between amazing coaching and mediocre or
poor coaching is what would players do
if they had no coach or leader and then
what would they do if they had the best
coach and best leader the Delta between
those two is the value of the coach the
value of the CEO the CEO needs to have
the highest return on time out of anyone
in the organization because they need to
always be solving the next problem as
long as when they replace their time the
activities they do with the new stuff
builds the business even more then that
trade will always work and if CEO can
come in and turn a business around even
behemoths around in two three years
based on the standard that they set and
the values that they stand for that
Delta across the entire organization is
your greatest leverage as a leader our
responsibility is to make the people
feel that we have their backs and
actually have their backs so there's a
sort of a nice anthropological if you
want me to go down this rabbit hole
there's a nice anthropology I find it
fascinating there's a nice
anthropological explanation which I
actually uh explained in that book
um which is which raises the question
why do we have leaders
um human beings are naturally
hierarchical
um we self-organize all the time it's
got nothing to do with whether you have
formal hierarchy like in an organization
we we're constantly self-organizing like
in a sports team who's who's the better
player we self-organize we pay we pay
deference to the one who is better you
know the scientist who publishes more or
the Nobel Laureate well the other
scientists pay deference right
um uh this is not by accident
um there's a very good anthropological
reason for it going back uh many years
you know human beings have only been
farming for the past 10 or 12 000 years
but we existed for tens of thousands of
years on the planet before that and we
lived in populations that were about 150
we maxed out at about about 150. which
raises a very interesting question we
they lived in austere times people are
hungry
um somebody you know brings back some
food to the tribe we all rush in to eat
um well if you're built like a football
player you can shove your way to the
front of the line right but this is a
bad system because if you punch me in
the face this afternoon I'm probably not
going to wake you and alert you to
Tanger tonight
um and so it's it's just a bad system
for cooperation which is if if we leave
every person to themselves
um and so we evolved into these
hierarchical animals we're constantly
assessing and judging who's higher in
the pecking order who's the alpha of the
of the group and when we assess that
someone has Alpha to us we naturally
step back we naturally defer and allow
our Alphas to eat first
um um and we get fed later and I don't
get an elbow in the face right good
system
this has survived to this modern day
there's not just not a single person on
the planet absolutely zero who has any
moral anger who is offended by the idea
that somebody more senior in the
organization makes a higher salary or
gets a nicer office or a better parking
space it offends nobody no we may think
they're useless at their job but the
fact that they make more money than us
because they're higher up in the
organization offends zero
um if you're senior and you leave your
coat in the other room someone will go
get it for you if your Junior and you
left your coat in the other room you get
your own coat in other words you get
treated differently
and this is why people want to get
promoted because they like the perks but
the perks don't come for free and that's
the point which is as you make your way
up the hierarchy as you achieve that
Alpha status of the tribe there's an
expectation that sure will give you
first choice of meat and we'll give you
first choice of mate but if danger
threatens the tribe you're going to be
the one who runs head first towards that
Danger first to protect us which means
you might die first right that's why we
gave you first choice of mate because we
want to keep your genes in the gene pool
we're not stupid
and and it's When leaders uh shirk that
responsibility that we start to have
moral outrage so for example nobody has
a problem with a CEO making more money
than they do the problem we have is when
you're willing to lay off your people to
protect your salary to protect your
bonus rather than find other ways to
protect the people this is what morally
offends us we have we made a deal
there's a deep-seated anthropological
deal that we've made with our Alphas
that you have to protect us you have to
and you have to do what it takes
sometimes sometimes putting your own
interests second
um and then and then you can but if
you're willing to do that we're proud
we're happy go enjoy you've earned it
um and so I think this is this is a
large part about building trust which is
it's not just about saying nice things
and being trustworthy it's that people
feel that you actually have their backs
and that you would be the one who take
responsibility take accountability look
for other ways to protect us if it meant
um we're gonna get hurt you see this
financial statement right now right here
everybody has one some of you are seeing
one for the first time in your life
financial statements everywhere in the
world whether I go to Cincinnati or
Singapore they're identical I go to
Dubai or I go to Taipei or I go to
Sydney Australia financial statement the
languages are different the culture is
different the foods are different
everybody agree the colors of the skin
might be different the financial
statement is the same everywhere
and they all start like this okay
there's there's there's this much of it
this the revenue of the company
typically there's this much revenue and
there's that many expenses
okay which one's more powerful
this is more powerful than that
okay I need to spend 95 of my time on
the top part of this you see where it
says Revenue gross sales Less sales
returns and allowances net sales that
little that little piece right there you
can take to Infinity
that you could take the zero and that's
it you can never get it lower than zero
and like if that don't Boggle your mind
if that little simple concept I can take
expenses to zero I can take gross sales
to to infinite how big can I imagine
okay how do I pay for the jet sales
how do I pay for the 19 country trips
sales
okay who's gonna give me a sale people
the Top Line those top line is people 95
of your time should be spent on income
and people
people have everything you want
the people that you know do not have
what you want the people that you don't
yet know have everything you've dreamed
of
so how old are you sir
57 years old the people that love him
and care for him that have taken care of
him that support him have had plenty of
damn time to change his life
he needs to now say okay I've been
looking at the wrong damn place
okay he now needs to meet the people
that can change his life because it's
not his mom his dad his uncle his
grandpa his kids the people that love
you are not going to change the quality
of your life they've had plenty of time
to do that we're always trying to
improve our lives but life is hard
things mess you up people judge you
finances are hard and you're always
trying to be your best but sometimes
that ain't easy and so I think
developing habits of mine Body Spirit
productivity service love
can really change your life and I'll
start this morning with a super funny
story uh about just a life-changing
habit of my you can see I'm in a new
space uh this morning I'm literally in a
shared office right now
and
if I I'll give you a play-by-play of
like the last
41 minutes
41 minutes ago
the power in my studio went out
I'm typing an email to I think about 41
minutes yeah about yeah 41 minutes if
I'm doing the right math right uh and I
figure out about that time that oh wait
no the it's the power to the whole house
and my studio my studio is in like Our
Guest House
and you know I've got the broadcast
camera you guys have all seen over the
years and you know it looks nice set up
and everything
all the create accounts in
um growth day about another promotion
and and also everything goes out
now I know I got this live with you guys
at the top of the hour and I was like
okay
didn't expect that
take a few deep breaths out
swear five times stand up and I go
outside looking for what's happening and
and like is there someone out there
they've turned off the power what's
going on across the street what's
because there's construction and I'm
looking around what's happening can't
figure it out go into the house and like
I said that whole house
power scenes out
go to uh ask Denise my wife
hey do you know anything is someone
doing anything with the house there's no
power I'm live in like an hour
she's like no I I I I don't know and
she'd just been getting out of the
shower she's like I don't know so I go
blazing outside
go look across the street there's
construction going on I pick up the
phone call the project manager over
there and I go did you guys just shut
off the power is something going on and
we're doing this Landscaping project so
I bolt over there asked you guys did you
guys are you digging are you digging
anything have you hit power no
and run back into the house
uh and Denise is like hey I just got a
notice from PG e
powers out but doesn't say anything
about just says notice we you know it's
kind of as Texas says hey your power
might be out like yeah we figured it out
so I go okay
uh I think okay well
um what am I gonna do
I'm live at the top of the hour so I
said okay well and probably come back on
you know probably yeah who's had that
Zoom moment where your power went out
you just thought it'll come back on
anyone else you're just like just Faith
you're thinking about it okay power's
gonna come back on
I said okay but what if it doesn't
so I start packing up a spare laptop
because my other laptop is connected to
all the gear right just in case it comes
on I've got that fancy camera and
everything
oh hold out and I run back inside I said
Okay
um
I'm gonna drive into town and get that
shared office space that we know about
hit up my assistant say can can you book
a space for me I'm gonna I'm gonna be
going in
and then the project manager from across
the street says hey it's not us God
knows from PG e and he sends me this
audio it says there will be no power
till one o'clock
which I'm on Pacific time so that's two
and a half that's three hours away but I
gotta be live with you at the top of the
hour
so okay I listen to the thing the audio
says no no power till one o'clock
the next text comes in from the project
manager hey
I'm coming I'm trying to come over uh to
see if it's anything about your property
because he also worked on our property I
can't get in the gate
we have a gate at the beginning of a
property that's powered
and so all of a sudden I realized
I can't get in my car and drive down to
the shared space because I can't get my
car out of our property the gate don't
open
I'm like oh my God
and this is where that first habit comes
in
I take a deep breath anytime there's a
huge Interruption I want to tell you I
saw
because I obsess on communication
because I know my wife because I love
being in love I love the fact that my
wife still looks at me every morning
like it's the first week we met it is
the most magical thing I could ever
share with anyone I walk in a room if my
wife looks at me she looks at me a way
that takes my knees out she still looks
at me like I'm the greatest human she's
ever seen and I feel so blessed and it
just makes me mirror that back to her
but I'm gonna tell you a little
something
my wife's a badass she had her own
business when I met her she was voted
the top hair stylist in Arizona eight
out of 10 years she has her own business
right next door
it's not easy being married to me
because I am like a steamroller and life
kind of because my business has gotten
so big and my schedule is so nuts a lot
of life has to revolve around me
I hate to say it but it's true it's I
travel a lot I have to go and speak I
have I'm partners with Tony my partner
Tony Robbins I hope also run Tony's
company and the company we own together
and my own company and I own over a
hundred different houses and I have a
real estate division and I'm writing a
new book and end and I want to be a good
dad to my older children and and
man a lot of life revolves around me so
you married a powerful amazing woman
who's used to having her Freedom control
of her time control of her business
control of everything and all of a
sudden you marry a man who's like you're
like hey I gotta be it's like no no they
were jumping on a plane I got to deal
the clothes in Malibu and where I got to
go to down to Florida and talk to Tony
and I want to tell you my wife's
business is amazing
but in comparison my wife has a great
year it could be hundreds and hundreds
of thousands I have a great year it's
tens of millions of dollars so there's
sometimes I'm being really personal now
I want to tell you how like why
communication is so important she could
say hey babe I was going to do this
thing and I in my head I'm like you're
going to do a 500 hair extension thing
that you want to do I'm going to close a
20 million dollar deal scrap that get on
the plane we're out of here right
those are some of the things I know I
did in previous relationships mine's
bigger mine's more important it's about
me be happy we're wealthy you get to
have freedom jump on the plane do what
the hell I say can you see how as a guy
that's easy to just say I got this I'm
working I got this hunt don't even worry
you never have to work again close your
shop close it down we don't need it
that's how
my my previous self thought of things
just being honest this is how we grow
but now I have to think about that all
the time and I make compromises and I
communicate with her in a way I say babe
what you did is absolutely amazing and
if you want me to shift that I'll move
my meeting and we adjust and we
communicate and she'll have the nerve to
come to me and say babe all last month
it was all about you can I work on a
little bit like oh my god did I do that
to you all right tell me and we'll
communicate and we'll talk I want to
tell you in my 30s it would have been
like uh mind is multi-millionaire yours
is peanuts my way or the highway without
even realizing I was saying that can you
guys understand I'm not a bad human I
didn't ever think I was doing I thought
I was working hard for my family it's
like I'm talking about leaving Legacy I
want to make sure my children and my
grandchildren and my great-grandchildren
are protected and I have you guys to
worry about in my project next family in
self-education family and my
Partnerships I have so much to worry
about it's me
how do you think my relationship would
be with my wife if it was all about me
how do you think it would be when I
walked in a room if I squashed her
dreams and her desires and just made it
all about me and didn't communicate I'm
just telling you the communication
skills you think you have right now that
are good they could be better because if
you would have asked me in my 40s about
if I was a good communicator I would
have said one of the best in the world
because I can close deals great I also
went through a divorce in my 40s
how good of a Communicator was I so you
don't have the right
to anything
the minute you become a business person
the idea that you have the right
must leave your mind
you don't have the right
at best you're hoping for the
opportunity
and because you want to succeed you have
created upon yourself the obligation
and you want to approach it with a sense
of humility
have the right
yeah
so when you the way you phrase the
question was I see a building it's owned
by X I would like to use that building
but I'm being told I need x amount of
money
and my answer to that didn't is what's
wrong with that
the owner of the building has the full
right to tell you what are the terms for
them for you to use their building
in the same as in 10 years time God
willing touch wood that building is
yours
when I come to and I said I'd like to
use your building I think you're going
to determine for me what are the terms
for me to use your building make sense
so this is important for us to get our
narrative right
you don't have the right guys you don't
have the right and I think it's
important for us to pause on this
because much of our national discourse
has been wrong
okay I don't want to be misunderstood
we created a narrative discourse of free
housing for all
then we said free education for all
and free this and free that
except month end somebody has to pay for
that which is free
and the economics of it are not very
complex if you build a free house who's
building it a contractor month end must
that contract to be paid yes because if
that contractor happens to be anybody
whether they are black or white they
have stuff that must be employed who
must be paid
so this free where does it start if the
cost to construct is paid for
they will argue from a macroeconomic
perspective that the state should fund
it and I don't want to have a long
meso-economic debate here that's not the
point of our Master Class
but in your mind when you become an
entrepreneur free
right must leave your head
you must presuppose you're going to pay
for everything you do
this master class how much did you guys
pay for this
I'm wondering how much did you pay free
it's free right
right so so the master class is free
who thinks that the electricity in this
room is free
no yeah what about the time of the very
capable and amazing technical people who
are recording and streaming and taking
pictures and the rest of it I think
that's free
so I'm here right
my whole team is here who thinks that's
free
make sense
what you're not aware of is that I have
a business model you just can't see it
but I've got a revenue model
it's going to make me more money than
you can imagine but I've got one in mind
what I've worked out
on a model called freemium I'm doing an
effect what Facebook does your Facebook
account is free or so you think it's not
really
yeah see I just figured out a different
way of how to do these things because
for me it's about empowering and sharing
but sooner or later somebody's gonna
have to pay the piper
so to answer your question
you can break into any industry you just
got to approach it right so what I would
do if I was you is I would go to them
and I would try and find a way where
they can meet you halfway rather than
have a
fiduciary pecuniary conversation
hey guys I'm a business I'd like to use
your business can we do some business I
wouldn't do it that way I'd approach it
at a human level
and I'd go to them and say this is what
I want to do
my mind is kind of fuzzy can we work
together to try and find a way to do it
does that make sense
uh I want to take the next question but
just to finish just to finish with your
question for a minute so if you guys
ever go on YouTube and you watch our
first Master Class
have you seen it yeah there must have
been like maybe 10 15 people in the room
and they're all sitting on like cam
chairs right
right so I want to say this to you
when you're an entrepreneur you have to
start
okay
in your mind what the what the business
You're Building you must see in your
mind all the time
but don't think where you're starting is
where you're going to be
so allow you just that it's like a just
just with the small thing do that one
and maybe maybe for them it's not
renting out the whole building maybe
it's just giving you a flaw
okay so do it that way
start Scrappy and and it's so important
I just want to just allow me to
reinforce this point it's so important
to start scrapping
because you can make all the mistakes
with the business that's this big so
when it's this big you know exactly what
the problems are
do you know what I mean there's some I'm
sure you guys would have seen it online
for those of you who watch the master
classes there's some master classes
where the video quality is terrible you
can barely hear the stuff yeah yeah yeah
but we did it yeah
you know and then in a year or two's
time people go whoa these are amazing
yeah but you didn't see the beginning
remember only you see the beginning you
know only you and a few early adopters
they see the beginning most people
usually come in at the end because you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
the five most important skills
entrepreneurs must have check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there if you're willing to sort of
ask a lot of questions and think about
things and work really hard you can
learn business pretty fast all of
listening whether I'm doing it with my
ears form with my eyes